Now let's illustrate Diffie-Hellman key
exchange algorithm using an example.
The prime number q is 353, and
the alpha,
which is the primitive root of q, is 3.
User A selects a random number,
which is a secret to herself, and
this value is 97.
So as you compute you, which is 3
raised to the power of 97 mod 353,
and the result is 40.
User B selects a random number,
which is a secret to himself and
this value is 233.
And you compute YB, which is 3 raised
to the power of 233 Mod 353,
and the result is 248.
And they exchange these values,
that is user A sends 40 to user B.
And user B sends 248 to user A.
Then user A computes the following,
Y8 rates to the power of X8.
In this case, will be 248 Raise
to the power of 97 mod 353.
And the result is 160.
Likewise, User B] computes you
raised to the power of XB, mod q.
In this case, it is 40 raised
to the power 233 mod 353.
And the result is 160.
So as you can see, by exchanging you and
YB, both users A and
B compute the same secret value,
which is 160.
And this would become the shared
secret key between users A and B.
We assume that an attacker would be
able to obtain these publicly exchanged
values which encode in public keys, and
they also know the publicly
known numbers Q and alpha.
In this case, because the integers
involved are very small.
It is feasible that the attacker
will be able to figure out
the secret value Xa and
Xb, which is 97 and 333.
However if very large number is
involved, such as when the prime number
Q is at least 200 bits long,
then a task of finding Xa,
the secret value,
from 1a the public value is not feasible